hello I'm Doug Walker and I'm not and
this is sibling rivalry thanks not
you're welcome you can't kill theater
I'm not afraid of you stand together
Santa Claus the Easter Bunny the tooth
fairy the Sandman in a bar and are
packing heat this is pretty much of a
setup for rise of the Guardians what
would happen if you gave your favorite
holiday characters weapons essentially
and while you might think that's a
pretty fucking stupid idea or the most
awesome idea you've ever heard or a
little bit of each yeah that's
essentially what we get we get a film
that is a clunky kind of clumsy but at
the same time is visually interesting
and unbelievably creative the setup is
pretty much that Jack Frost played by
Justin Bieber as you can see uh I know
Justin Bieber at that in a hoodie is the
new Guardian that's going to be brought
on to fight the boogeyman with Santa
Claus the Easter Bunny and so forth they
basically play a sort of a holiday
version of the Expendables hired by the
moon to kick that's right the mo yes
they've incorporated Sailor Moon into
it's Emma in the name of the Moon they
will punish the boogeyman uh yeah that
mood the moon is essentially Charlie who
doesn't talk if at the Sandman doesn't
talk either there's a lot of not talking
and too much talking at times ah so what
let's just get down to exactly let's
talk about the pros of this movie like
just the really good stuff uh I thought
visually this movie was unbelievable
it's incredibly imaginative which is not
something I was expecting by the
marketing this is another horribly
marketed film that look terrible
absolutely terrible and I walked into it
wanting to see Lincoln but numbnuts here
saw their widdy's like no we're going to
review rise of the Guardians and I had
no intention of going I was like are I
fine I'll do it for the review but um I
was pleasantly surprised and the thing
that surprised me the most was um the
layout design I'm an animation junkie
the backgrounds the layout design the
animation is all just itself the
textures unbelievable the textures were
incredible the imagination but behind
the different lands I like to think of
this as sort of The Nightmare Before
Christmas if you've got to see all of
the holiday towns instead of just goes
down you you get to see the the tooth
fairy's Kingdom which is really
interesting I never thought I would say
that the tooth fairy's Kingdom is
probably one of the more interesting
ones in the movie it looks like
something like cross between Final
Fantasy and Rainbow Brite
yeah like skin avatar yeah yeah and all
the worlds are have their own unique I
mean they're all pretty massive and I
think for lack of a better description
they look like something kind of a
modern-day video game but that's not a
bad thing I mean they look really pretty
and they look well and they were all
given unique identities which was nice
even including the boogeyman's like
s-sure Kingdom with all the stairs and
the the hanging sort of you know what
with that so let's actually talk about
the characters themselves the actual
Guardians because as this movie was
starting off us you know as we saw the
trail ongoing at Sheetz this is gonna be
really lame and really awkward and at
times it was but part of the fun was the
interaction off of these characters and
again the design of these characters who
the fuck would design the Tooth Fairy
like that that is an original joint
fairy that was the best design in the
whole movie hey it took me a lot of
catch on what they were doing because
she looks kind of like a cross between a
parent and a hummingbird with the face
of Julie we Dreyfuss for some reason um
and I couldn't figure it out I'm like
what what the hell is this you know no
book I've ever seen is a tooth fairy
ever been a hummingbird and then over
time you know about your fairy lore III
do I am a goddammit expert I wrote the
Wikipedia article on it just so you know
straight and married but no it's um no
it was really interesting and I finally
figured I was like okay so you're doing
the fairy thing but you have to find a
way around it and hummingbirds they
collect the teeth and I was like okay so
we have all these little hummingbirds
collecting teeth for the Queen humming
her giant hymen this would almost be a
horror movie actually if you just kind
of twisted it a bit but uh and I think
the I think the biggest shock for both
of it was your favorite character in the
movie it's probably mine too
uh my I have two favorite characters
actually uh honestly I would go with the
tooth fairy mostly because I think she
had the most humanity and was the most
imaginative you know from the ground up
that one was reinvented totally I would
say second Santa Claus yes Santa Claus
Claus in this Murray Russian Santa is so
he's so enjoyable
did you kisses Alec Baldwin Eric Bolling
no I I totally did not guess that was
Aldo you cannot recognize him and no my
wife and I watched the film and we
turned to each other and we were like
Alec Baldwin and that's true headed
everyone all he is just great yeah
straight out of Team America isn't Gary
Barwon what a great great performance
that is not somebody I would ever
associate with Santa Claus um nor would
I ever associate him with anything good
and decent in this world but sure enough
he really comes through as this really
deranged but enjoyably energized Santa
Claus I think that's that's probably one
of the things that's really good about
its enjoyably energized every second
that did you see the 3d no I do not see
the 3d is very 3d the 3d is very good in
this movie I think DreamWorks is one of
the few people they actually really know
how to do I don't know what they do but
he had the 3d technology did master it
with How to Train Your Dragon so yeah
and this was just as good in my opinion
the cameras are constantly flying
constantly spinning around constantly
going through and you feel like you're
flying half the time of these scenes
they were well put together action
sequences and they found interesting
ways to get around the fat because this
always bothers me about kids films where
it always comes down to oh you need to
believe in EM only we could understand
each other and and and good and this man
always comes down to extreme violence by
there's like always a mixed moral but
they found a way around it by basically
making the the terrifying characters
sort of nightmares these these sort of
dreamlike things so Sandman's like
whipping these things and Santa Claus is
kicking ass and the Easter but
is played by Hugh Jackman and is kind of
like a cross between Crocodile Dundee
and Chuck Norris as a jackrabbit I don't
know but and it works because I'm just
like okay well they're imaginary you can
be extremely violent so I got my taste
for blood lust and I didn't feel guilty
that we were corrupting me up in America
but the pie thing is that the most
enjoyable the action scenes are fun but
the most enjoyable scene for me in the
entire film was a scene where all of
them have to go because the tooth
fairy's losing her powers they all have
to get the teeth and that was the most
enjoyable thing cos they're just jumping
attack rooftops and I having a
competition for who can get the most the
fastest and it is really energizing you
see them working off each other and
they're very likeable and they're
enjoying it while they're doing it and I
will say this is a problem this is both
a pro and con with the movie is it
borrows a lot from other films that
scene was straight out of Nightmare
Before Christmas it was like oh it's
like Jack Skellington taking over
another holiday and they all suck at it
you know well they're they're good to
varying degrees but they're beating the
snot out of each other trying to grab
all these teeth again sounds like a
horror movie the problems because I
think we can both agree that there's
some problems with the movie the major
one for me uh was the pacing because
even though there's a lot of scenes are
a lot of fun and you do like seeing
these characters interact off each other
I'm constantly saying to myself wow this
movie doesn't slow down much just cuz it
well we have to go over here do this
okay now there's something around the
cameras get super over here and go down
that that down well okay that was about
nice well we can do that logo over here
okay the camera zoom down to do this in
blah blah blah it didn't seem to have
many slow movements like for example
when the boogeyman introduces himself
there's no big introduction he just
comes out says I'm the boogeyman
that's it essentially what do you want
him to do tap an so no I I want build up
my dazing was fine no III want build up
I want rare exception I didn't think
there was really a dull moment in the
movie where I'm just like you know well
I mean I guess to me like for the real
emotional moment and the review and they
work out okay but I guess like you were
take a jab cross backstory like nobody
that's a resident no that's a perfect
example that's a good set up and without
giving it away it's a good set up for
his backstory um but at the same time
you had the music going his voice is a
little I don't know if that's the right
voice for him I mean they a little you
there on this cuz you're wrong about the
pacing but I will agree with you on this
Chris Pine and Jude Law horribly miscast
unbelievably miscast and it's not their
fault yeah like they do fine it's just
you know the fault is not I'm not even
saying the fault is in the voice the
fault is in the character design and
this and I'm going to rant about this
for a second because the this movie is
so imaginative that when it fails in the
imagination department it's so much more
obvious because everything around it is
so good and the secondary characters are
all great the backgrounds are
spectacular humans not animated well I
thought that was very strange and some
of the animations weird Santa Clauses
beard looks like it's made out of
frosting it has no sense of texture but
your main character is okay so who are
you who are your main characters gonna
because the others are side characters
your basic going Jack Frost and the
villain Jude lon this is your central
set up boring they're both everyboy
horribly boring first off the villain
has no backstory I kept waiting for it
like well there's gonna be something
that no hi I'm just sick of not being
believed I just want to be a tick and
the move got mad what the hell not
really one's gonna get too high it
doesn't have no backstory and then in
the case of Jack Frost it's just a
miscalculation in character design
albino Justin Bieber and his hoodie does
not he has a buddy guys it's like one of
these things is not like the other and
it's I know if they're trying to do it's
DreamWorks at times like we gotta be hip
we know what's in item yes we bieber
does staff and the powers of these guys
ship is you can be lackeys not know born
a nice i like the idea of making
mischievous I like the Avengers okay bad
way but they didn't yet they've made
they tried to make him a little too
modern up not painfully so I mean it's
not like you know Disney Jane to be my
dear boy I was like that was a much it's
noticeable that was my other problem
with the movie is for all of the like oh
Santa's sleigh has like Rockets
attachment and for the the way they
tried to modernize um making uh
you know the toys and getting them out
there and the globe with all of the
little twinkling lights and the computer
stuff did you really need anyone that
the globe's were pretty cool no well
here I'll just low it looked like a bad
James Bond set no I'll give it oh no
I'll talk about a globe where that we're
like the portals see anything like that
once or supernatural anger fits they had
the magic moves they do Tim too much
technical stuff they have much that they
did here and there and it's just like I
agree whether it's one of these things
is not like you not magic it did not fit
um so yeah I will agree that those
didn't quite go together I don't think
that was as distracting as other
elements but I think for me yeah it's
yes yes you don't confuse you dig you I
dig we're supposed to be really great in
him yeah there's been a great film and I
think when you have a character like
Jack Frost who is actually pretty well
set up but give him a good backstory
they give him a good purpose and a good
longing and stuff like that um I think
just the voice doesn't quite come
through again not his fault it's just
the wrong choice um and for me I think
there's just not enough I didn't feel
his connection in there with the other
Guardians which I mean perhaps what's
the point as well I'm he's supposed to
be a little bit of the outcast um yeah I
never got to see that's the problem they
were setting that up you you're just a
troublemaker you know which again seeing
Santa Claus kind of be a bastard yes
we're all the source of that I have
nothing troublemaking nothing this is
the most twisted Santa I've seen since
um Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe where
you know father Christmas is a miami's
he's producing and a scimitar for pizza
Santa we've seen that Ed she carries
weapons around still one step below the
robot Santa Claus from Futurama knows so
but yeah he just had I never got this
sense of connection even at the end
where everything wraps up in a nice
package into the film's credit it comes
up with an ingenious way to take out
your villain without it having to be
like literally kill your villain cuz I
was like if Samus malas kill somebody
this movie I think we may have a problem
I'm all for you know a dark Christmas I
like this is kids Ville I may have to
kind of
like you know go up wait a second oh
yeah the resolution for how he happy
without giving away how he is taken care
of is actually very smart and it's kind
of self-destructive to which I yeah I
and I think that's a much better it's a
much more adult observation about
villains in general you know there is
something about karma in that film and
that's one of the things I liked about
this movie is for all of its whiz-bang
action and all this it wasn't strangely
don't film like it could have been more
adult may not be here's my other thing
at the very end what would you say the
ultimate lesson is or lessons um don't
skate on thin ice I mean well the best
thing at the end it seems like and
they're all good lessons and they're all
adult lessons but it seems like they're
throwing five or six lessons at you and
maybe that's part of my problem since I
Justin Bieber maybe he needs a lot of
less but that's why I'm saying that it
seems like maybe a little too much was
being thrown at you and you didn't like
here's my thought on this movie this is
what I think would have made this a
great movie why did you need a villain
when you have just made it that Jack
Frost is gonna be one of the new
guardians one of the new I hate people
and as the opposite in process I look at
it is why did you need check for us I
mean I can't until his backstory then
I'm like can I get out now but it took
it did take its time there but but one
of those things it seems like two movies
are trying to happen one that's really
magical really imaginative and one
that's essentially an action film and
they don't always mesh sometimes they do
I mean that's really where I very
imagine then that is a problem but I
will take a film with good action and
five or six morals that are decently
told enough over cars to any desk
yes I'm I so sorry like I think it's
we're at a time in America where we can
start judging animated films on Mars and
I think it just by cars too well that
too but I think we can look at these
things and say you know what I'll take
something that's ambitious and it's
trying a lot of things over pure you
know fluff like I look at cars Jelena
what was the moral of Monsters Inc boo
hi like yeah yeah I mean I'm try yeah
that's the same thing I
no and honestly I'm gonna say I enjoyed
this movie more than a movie like cars -
or monsters no not cars - you you take
that back
iPad - the minute movie class said it
you rewrite here send angry emails car -
oh I'm gonna get the emails for monsters
angers it but the baby was so cute but
there was nothing happening nice babies
day I don't asking designs of cars -
Club come out and be like hey we
represent cars do you leave that movie
along as I'm yet to see someone who
likes that what befell me behind as a
cop was brilliant Michael Caine's gets
Michael Froman you ha ha ha um ok so so
we should probably wrap this review up
um I think we can both serve a great
it's a good movie it could have been
great but I give it one thumb yeah oh
yeah just give it a jab in that no it's
like if this is pure average like this
sucks
average thumbs up then you take towards
the 10 o'clock maybe 10:30 like I'd say
the stuff that was especially 3d again
the stuff that was imaginative and
creative and visually interesting was
unbelievable the animation is
unbelievable
and I think that allows were seeing the
movie but if that doesn't sway you you
might have a harder time getting into it
um but well and there's a couple things
to keep in mind one I think the I think
the action is fine I love Roger Ebert we
did a tribute to him but he was gone
eyes like I don't think this is the
movie for me I think this movie is meant
for four-year-old to like action
sequences and Roger
you gave three-and-a-half stars to the
Phantom Menace and as a 40-minute
podrace in the middle you can lighten up
a bit I think it's the actions fine it's
fun I think it's better paced than
anything in the Phantom Menace well I
think we should point out to the it's
nuts like it's action-packed I wouldn't
say it's necessarily violent necessarily
like no and I think it's a little er
it's a rollercoaster ride yeah like it's
not like there's a lot of punching or
hey there are people getting stabbed or
anything like that it's very much as
people dodging things you know moving
out of the way it may be I know beams of
light hitting somebody building is
anybody seeing this movie Devon yes
remember is this is a first time
director that was impressed
first time this isn't an
african-american director college
dropout storyboard artists unsung heroes
of Hollywood storyboard artists these
are the guys that Willie in some sense
make your movie happen because they're
drawing the visual representation that's
going to be filmed and he rose up
through the ranks of DreamWorks this is
his first film I you know it's a good
first film for a first try I mean I even
look at things like you know Brad Bird
and the Iron Giant and you can even look
at the original Toy Story and you can
still find flaws so I'm not saying this
is necessarily quite in the same ranks
is Toy Story or Iron Giant but it's in
the upper echelon ZUP for a first try
okay it's pretty solid film so I
invested him yeah I mean technically and
in terms of imagination it's really up
there so yeah I think that's all we had
to say about this film uh I'm better
than you and we shall see you next time
you suck you suck